Hey you, are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masjid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.
concept of martyrdom then I would
consider that to be an advantage.
Frankly, the one who's willing to commit
suicide has the initiative.
How are you guys doing?
>> Alhamdulillah. I'm okay. You okay?
>> Yeah. Alhamdulillah. Thanks for asking,
bro.
>> Let's get straight into it, man.
>> Yes. [laughter]
madness.
>> There's a lot a lot of things to laugh
about.
>> Yeah.
>> Because the thing is they don't they
wanted to know how to deal with me.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I've been I've been a thorn in
their side, the far right and the
Zionists and and the enemies of Islam
and these people, they wanted to know
how to deal with me. So, at first they
tried to refute me in debate.
>> They couldn't do it.
>> Okay?
>> And then they tried to bankrupt me.
>> THEY DID IT. [laughter]
TO add [laughter]
insult to injury. Yeah.
>> To add insult to injury. Now they're
trying to bismerch my good name. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> And so I'm just minding my own business
and I see
>> a flood, an avalanche of comments and oh
>> I'm trending on Twitter again.
>> What was it? something I said recently.
I've been quite quiet, you know, I've
been doing my own thing. No, it's
something I said a long time ago and
it's been taken fully out of context,
hasn't it, Zean?
>> So, they're trying to make it seem like
you're trying to promote suicide
bombing.
>> They've taken a clip.
>> Yes.
>> And it's scandalous what they've done
with the clip. Absolutely scandalous.
We're going to play the clip now
>> and you guys are going to see where
their clip stops and the real one
carries on
>> the concept of martyrdom. Then I would
consider that to be an advantage.
Frankly,
because as Robert Green said, the one
who's willing to commit suicide has the
initiative. Now, I'm not saying commit
suicide anyone. This how we got him
here. Not talking about suicide mission
here, bro. I'm just saying figuratively.
The one who's willing to take it
further. From my understanding, the
avalanche started with Douglas Murray.
Yeah. So, Douglas Murray rubbing the
salt in the wound saying, "Yeah, hijab
has declared a bankruptcy this and
that." And we all know, it's no secret
Douglas Murray has been the asset and
the poster boy of Israel during the
genocide. He's been singing for Israel
since this genocide has ensued.
Straight after
>> he made his tweet,
>> Tommy Robinson jumped on. Tommy two
shekeles Robinson. Yeah. Mr. Yaxley
Lennon.
>> Mo hijab this. Mo hijab that. Mo.
>> So [laughter]
>> So he started with that. But what's
crazy is that when when you say trending
Yeah. I did a bitamar research and there
were 38,000
posts
>> in a space of 24 hours.
>> No way.
>> Absolutely. [laughter]
>> Absolutely.
>> About the jump.
>> There should be 50,000 actually.
[laughter]
>> Come on. Come on enemies. You can do
better than that.
>> Yeah. You think this is hurting me? Give
me 50,000. Give me 50. Give me 100,000.
Huh? What's what's crazy that this tweet
this this misquing started on a page
called Opensource Intel
>> with 912,000
followers.
>> Where is that?
>> It's not just Israel.
>> It's northern Israel.
>> Subhan Allah. Well, I'm so glad that
people from northern Israel are thinking
about the champ because if Look, let me
just tell you something. Yeah.
>> The Quran tells us with certain people,
we have to hate them in it. We hate you.
I actually love that you hate me too.
And I would feel bad if you love me. So
if you hate me, it's like, do you know
when you say to your wife or you say to
your child, "I love you." And you mean
it and you like you feel warm when
you're doing that. I feel almost the
same way about hating you.
that between us and you as the Quran
mentions is emnity
and opposition forever. So if people
from northern Israel Yeah. who are
northern Israel who genocide supporters
>> don't want to attack the champ 50,000
post 20 100,000 million posts. Thank
you. Thank you. What makes it even worse
is that as you guys saw in the clip, and
I'll play it again. Yeah, this bit in
particular. Straight after he made the
point about suicide bombing, all of us
>> have been, In fact, it wasn't even about
suicide bombing. He was talking about
suicide and linking it. Yeah.
Figurative. It wasn't even suicide
bombing. People don't know. It's a
principle of Robert Green.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I was actually quoting him.
the one who has um what do you call it
is willing to commit suicide has the
initiative is a quote from Royal Green
>> and then literally two seconds later he
goes
>> now I'm not saying commit suicide anyone
just how we got him here not talking
about suicide mission here bro I'm just
saying figuratively
>> and they missed the irony completely
unashamedly
>> clipped it and then you went further by
saying again unabashedly
>> no that's another one for you
>> absolutely Then you had a barrage of
Jewish pages, of Israeli pages, and far
right pages.
>> Oh yes.
>> Now the Israeli pages, one was Mark
Leaven with 4.9 million followers.
>> And here's what it says on his Wikipedia
page, as you guys can see on the screen,
>> that he is a supporter of Israel. I'm
glad that he's making this post then.
You've just made my day.
>> Yeah, I'm actually feeling good as I'm
>> Yeah, I'm actually getting some pleasure
out of it. Unfortunately, for for this
guy [laughter] making me feel good.
>> I don't blame you.
>> Making me feel good.
>> If the only way they can take you down
is by by editing you scandalously like
that,
>> I'm important now. I'm important now.
>> Then the second one. Yeah. Then the
second. So you got Mark 11, the other
Israeli page. Literally, how do you know
it's Israeli? It's called, and I kid you
not, Israel's Victory.
>> Is that what it's called? [laughter]
>> It's called Israel's Victory for God's
sake.
>> Okay.
>> The Jewish pages. Zashan, how do you
know they're Jewish? Well, one of them's
called the Jewish idea.
>> I think it's safe to assume they're
Jewish. The other one is literally named
in Hebrew. Then if you look at farr
right Basil the great
>> with 267,000
followers a far right famous page on X.
>> Then you've got GB News host.
>> We know them.
>> Yeah. GB News getting involved as well
with 249,000
followers. Then you've got Ian Chong
>> based in the UAE. Some before he used to
be in I think Indonesia. Yeah. Again a
farright guy with 1.2 million followers.
But here's where they took it a step
forward.
>> I saw a bunch of pages reporting him to
the police.
>> No [laughter] way.
>> But here was my favorite.
>> Here was my favorite though. This is
what you don't know.
>> There's there's a few of them that not
only reported him to the police,
>> but the home secretary [laughter]
>> and the prime minister of the UK.
>> They do you know when they should have
reported me to the police? They should
have reported me to the police after the
first Piers Morgan debate. [laughter]
They should have reported me to the
police when they s saw me giving those
immaculate and phenomenal lectures
online. They should have reported me to
the police when I took my shirt off and
showed my muscles. They should have
reported [laughter]
>> to the fashion police.
>> Listen, there's a lot of reasons why you
guys should be calling the police,
[laughter] but I've never made somebody
so triggered.
>> Yeah. Imagine making someone so
triggered. Yeah. That they have to call
the police, bro. [laughter]
Online. Go and call the police. Aki,
call the police.
>> Now, now here, now here's the thing.
Yeah. Like I said, 2 seconds later,
after he made that millions of people,
two seconds later, he literally gave the
context. I'm not calling for suicide.
I'm using it figuratively. And then he
makes his joke as well. Ah, we got him
now. Like, you can't say that. That's
literally what they did. That's now this
is this is indicative because you know I
go speaker's corner and I see when
people come they love quoting the ayah.
Yeah. Oh. So when you see the
disbelievers kill them wherever you see
them.
>> Okay.
>> That's one of many. And all they have to
do is look at the ayah before and the
ayah after. That's it.
>> They just need to take things out of
context for agenda. Look, if if Muslims
were really such bad people, surely you
can give the complete
>> Why are you lying?
>> Yeah, you don't need to lie.
>> You don't need to lie.
>> Yeah, just there. Surely there should be
plenty of content
>> because anyone now using chat GPT or
using AI using like just factchecking
can disprove you and then when they
realize you're lying about it because
you've just distorted someone's speech
and defamed somebody and become an
unintegrous and dishonorable person in
so doing. Yeah. When you've done that,
that what you've done is actually
admitted your own weakness.
>> Yeah.
>> You've shown your own desperation.
>> You've shown your own desperation
because what you've shown is that you
can't on a fairminded and neutral basis
>> intellectually,
point for point, pound for pound, defeat
the opponent. You need to resort to
this. It's like when Ivan Holyfield and
Mike Tyson were fighting and Ivan
Holyfield was giving him a very hard
time. Then Mike Tyson [laughter] bit
him. That's You're trying to bite my
ear.
>> You're trying to bite my ear. You're
trying to keep biting it.
>> Yeah.
>> Keep nibbling on that [laughter] because
anything is making me feel good. Trust
me, you got nothing.
>> It's not even like they're hiding it.
Like you debated Rabbi Shmuli. Rabbi
then the lawyer of uh Jeffrey Epstein.
Yeah. Durowitz. Durowitz. that was put
in contact with Epstein
>> to his admission by the Roth child.
>> Yeah. One of the Rothschilds. You can't
make this stuff up. In fact, I'm
surprised it took them this long.
>> This long
>> to to to come up.
>> They were doing it before. I mean, don't
forget Douglas Mar done it and the
spectator. There's waves of it. This is
like this this is like the 10th wave or
something.
>> This is the 10th wave. But this wave is
something that you guys now will be
familiar with. This is a technique that
some of you may have heard that they
have groups and and they've been exposed
on Telegram. There are groups of
Israelis where they are literally told
this is the page, this is the person
we're going after.
>> Just go for it.
>> Yeah, go for it. Yeah. It's Israelis
that do this.
>> It's not just that now
>> and it's the do as well.
>> They are funding, bro. So they are
funding people who look like Muslims,
who sound like Muslims, who wear Muslim
garb, who go on Tik Tok, who go on
Twitter or go on YouTube, and who create
scandalous situations, and they talk
about these things and whatever.
>> And they're actually funding some of
those people,
>> infiltrators,
>> and and you know, these infiltrators,
there's going to be evidence that comes
out against them very soon. Uh, and once
the evidence is presented, we'll it's
going to show you that this is an entire
complex. But I will say one thing
though. Yeah. One thing I will say is
the Muslim community
has been has been behind us.
>> Absolutely.
>> Like let's be honest, bro. We don't have
no budget.
>> I'm bankrupt. [laughter]
What we were talking about,
>> you know, there's only a certain amount
of money I can spend in a monthly basis.
That's what being bankrupt actually
means. In the UK, I can't have over a
certain amount. So today, one of my
banks account closes closed down. You
>> Yeah. Lloyd TSB gave me a call and was
the classic account was closed down and
they said you have to go, you know, you
have to get this and you have to do that
and whatever. So, you know what I'm
trying to say to you is the following is
that we don't have the budget.
>> We don't have what these guys have.
We're the underdogs here. We are the
David in this David and Goliath story.
>> Ironically enough, yeah,
>> we're Look at Look at the equipment that
we have. Yeah. Because it's the Muslim
community, the um
>> Islam
>> because it's the baraka of Allah and the
angels come down and they help us and
they help the Muslims. Because of that,
I believe we will still be victorious
and we will still be the thorn in their
side for a very very very long time
until their desperation becomes even
more apparent and more apparent and more
apparent and then they will show their
cards entirely and do something
embarrassing.
>> Absolutely. And in fact, you know,
although that's a very nice place to
kind of draw it to a close, but it
reminded me of what they did to Jeremy
Corbyn when they went after him.
>> Yeah. Not only did he, you know, not win
the election, but then afterwards they
started hounding him, chasing him,
labeling him, and then, you know, trying
to, you know, bismerch him. It's just
not enough
>> for them to take someone off their
position. Yeah. They have to go after,
but then they go after with lies. Oh,
apologize over here. Do this, do that.
And it it's just it's just not enough.
But alhamdulillah, yeah, the Muslim
community has seen what Israel has
employed in the last year or so. Yeah.
The strategies, these Telegram groups
and the weaponization of X, the
weaponization of the far right. And you
guys can see, you guys saw on the
screen. Yeah. I posted the screenshots
of these very pages with the big
followings unashamedly. Before you'd
have to go, you know, click over here,
go over there, find out they're from
Israel, find out. Now it's clear. It's
obvious. They're not even hiding it.
>> But let me tell you one last thing is,
and I think this is where we should end
it here, but this is probably the most
important point from my perspective,
which is that all of this is a
distraction from the genocide, bro.
>> Mhm.
>> They're trying to distract us from the
fact that they are still perpetrating
what every single major human rights
organization in the world considers to
be a genocide. Yeah. They're moving
people, ethnic cleansing, destroying
buildings. They are they have shown
themselves to be craven cowards. The
worst of humanity, the worst of
humankind. You guys are the worst. Wall
wahi. Sometimes I'll be honest with you,
and I'm going to be vulnerable with you
guys since I've been pompous in the in
the past. So, here's a here's a a moment
of vulnerability. Yeah. Sometimes I do
question my own
you know my own goodness my own my own
you know character let's say I say am I
am I good enough I always do actually
yeah it's something I do if there's any
insecurity I have
>> I don't have intellectual insecurities
>> I don't have physical INSECURITIES
[laughter]
>> it's going so well
>> but no but if there's any insecurities
is that I have it's insecurities
relating to my person. Okay, I'm
excessive. You guys have seen that I'm
over the top. Sometimes I'm impulsive,
whatever.
And sometimes I just think am I just all
around a bad person? And wahi and I say
this is from Allahh.
When Israel attacks me this harshly with
all of its proponents, all of its
constituent parts, all of its organs,
all of its tentacles,
>> I actually start to think to myself,
well, I can't be that bad because the
worst people in the world are pointing
their arrows towards me. And as M Shafi
mentioned, if you want to know where the
truth is or the people of the truth are,
then see where the enemies of Islam,
where the arrows of the enemies of Islam
are pointing.
>> And when I see the the arrows of the
enemies of Islam pointing towards me, it
gives me some kind of indication
that Allah is happy with the work that
we are doing.
>> Alhamdulillah. Especially after I'll
play the clip now as well. Netanyahu
clearly admitting
>> and of course it's most prevalent in the
social media. This is the new
battlefield and this is where we must
counter with our own weapons. We're late
in the game but we will win this battle
too as we won on the battlefield because
we are developing the means to fight
this.
>> They're literally telling you what
they're doing.
>> It's not they're not hiding it. But
alhamdulillah.
>> Alhamdulillah. And look, you can make us
bankrupt. Look, back in the days, they'd
go into fight. They could probably clip
this up as well. Yeah. But let's just
say because we're not going to back down
from this is our religion.
>> You used to fight classically and
historically. Yeah. In the battlefield
and people used to lose their arm. You
they used to get killed, get hurt, this
whatever. And in Islam, they would be
rewarded for that. Yeah. Because we
believe that if the enemy hurts you in
the battlefield, if the enemy kills you,
you become a martyr. If the enemy harms
you or hurts you, then you are you are
rewarded for that in the hereafter.
Yeah. So if we have to go out and do da
in front of a camera like this and the
ramification is that we get 40,000 or
50,000 people posting about us out of
nowhere in a span of 24 hours, I can be
trending. Yeah, which I think I'm
trending now in the UK in Twitter. Then
that's nothing really. But we hope
somehow that it's a reward for us on the
day of judgment. That's why because this
this framework makes you feel so good
about yourself that you become
impervious to the kind of criticism of
outside forces. If you are true to what
you believe in and everyone in the world
criticizes you, then actually the
criticism acts as a way of making you a
happy person. And with that, you should
know that you can't harm us with this
stuff, you know, because there's nothing
you can do to make us
go astray from the mission that we have,
which is to advance Islam and the case
for [snorts] Muslims.
Your brothers and sisters in Islam net
from Norway are establishing a masid, a
da center. This center, this masid, this
educational institution will act like a
beacon of light, calling the Muslims in
Norway back to the essence of Islam. So
give generously and Allahel will give
you even more.